hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the beginning
of his second meditation from his
meditations on First Philosophy Rene
Descartes is going to focus on the human
being in what he takes to be its most
essential nature that is as a being that
thinks or rather as a being whose very
nature is to be thinking this is often
talked about in terms of a famous
formula which shows up in other works
Kouji tow ergo sum I think therefore I
am the curt is actually not using that
formula here rather he is saying I exist
I am therefore I exist or I have being
therefore I exist but he's connecting it
together with thinking and some very
important and interesting ways so we can
talk here about the code youto
understanding that it's sort of a
shorthand for the space of the thinking
being it actually spaces a little bit of
a metaphorical term here because it's
not extended in space so Descartes
begins by considering this problem
deception perhaps I am deceived by some
evil genie
or some evil demon some genius who
devotes all of his resources to
deceiving me
I still can't be deceived about
everything because insofar as I am
deceived there has to be a me to be
deceived so one of the things that I
cannot be successfully deceived about
and which I can doubt in the sense of
like saying I'm doubting this but as
soon as I start looking at it closely I
realize I can't actually doubt this is
my own existence my own being and
existence and Descartes does in fact use
this formula several times you know just
sweet she exists I am therefore I exist
and it's you know whether there's a
difference between the two of them it's
not quite clear in the text itself but
he is affirming I exist there's a sort
of reflexivity to it
I cannot successfully doubt my own
existence even if somebody is trying to
fool me about that so that's great I
exist I have this sort of reflexive
relation to myself but what am i and he
says well I'm a man no I'm right a human
being and I've been told that I'm a
rational animal you know that's the sort
of traditional conception of human being
that philosophers have often given but
do those really help me he says no
because they don't actually know what
being a man or a human being is and if I
was going to say I'm a rational animal
an animal a phrasal knob he says that
wouldn't help because then I would have
to figure out what is an animal and what
is reasonable and from one question we
fall
in perceivably into an infinity of
others even more difficult and tangled
up together embarrass a in the French
and I don't want to use my time on that
is there any other way he asks that I
can figure out what the hell I am what
this being that does have existence is
and he starts thinking about all the
different things that he up until this
time his thought belonged to him and he
considers you know bodily matters but
eventually he settles on thinking and he
says thinking that is something that's
really essential to me that is something
as a attribute that really belongs to me
that is proper to me so what this allows
us to say is I'm a thing that thinks
that's the very nature of what it is to
be me so he says this is the only thing
that cannot be detached from me just
sweetie exist I am I exist that is
certain and now he brings up a very
interesting side note how long is that
actually certain well so long as I'm
thinking about it and there's a lot of
jokes out there where Descartes walks
into a bar and somebody says do you want
a glass of water and he says I think not
and then poof he vanishes out of
existence and those are you know
greatest jokes but as far as
understanding decartes philosophy
they're totally off-base because even to
say I think not is to be thinking it's
to have some sort of conception going on
as we're going to see there are many
different modes of thought but if he
says if I were to stop thinking perhaps
I would leave existence says this is a
possibility if I ceased thinking then I
would at the very same time cease to be
or to
exists but he says I can't at this point
admit that this isn't necessarily true
so I am a thing that thinks what is that
then that is he says that is to say a
mind in his play right or you can say
spirit if you like and then he says an
intellect or reason an unfounded ma or
gray zone right and he says these are
the terms whose signification was before
unknown so he says ok so I'm a thing
that is true and is truly existing but
what thing he says well I've said it a
thing that thinks and what else
now here is where we get to something
very important oftentimes left out for
Descartes as for everybody within the
Cartesian tradition that follows him
thinking is not something that is simply
reducible to one mode of thought as a
matter of fact pretty much all the stuff
that we do involves thinking in one way
or another he also adds something before
we look at that that's quite important
he talks about how it is that I have a
concept a notion in French word we can
translate his notion as well and also
knowledge honey sauce that's not savoir
right that's knowing you could say by
acquaintance knowing intimately in this
way myself I know my thoughts I've been
with my thoughts my thoughts are myself
so then a little bit later
he asks great so what is it that I am
I'm a thing that thinks but what is the
thing that thinks and
here he starts to enumerate different
modes of thinking that he knows that he
engages in and we as the reader can say
yes I engage in those as well this
describes me a thing that thinks is a
thing that doubts so even in doubting he
exists even in doubting he is his
thinking right that is the essence of
who he is something that conceives
something that affirms something that
denies something now notice the shift
that we're making here those were all
more or less cognitive now we arrive at
something that we could say is
volitional or cognitive and here we have
something that wills and that wills not
right or wills against in in the Latin
it's Volans and knowlins and no and no
larae means to will against something
else the French translation has doesn't
will but but that's not quite strong if
it wills against that thing
it says no to it and then we also have
imagines now we're in the realm of the
senses and feels something that has
emotions Descartes will consider
emotions to be modes of thought
something that is an idea that is often
at odds with the way that we look at it
today and so all of these things he says
belong to my nature and he goes into
some some thinking about we know how
these fit into things and he says do I
actually do these and he gives examples
he says I imagine things all the time
don't I
and I feel things
I feel sensations I feel emotions I
doubt whether I'm here in the room right
now and we could go on and on
with each of these examples as he does
in meditation - in thinking about the
different modes of thought that are
essential to our existence as thinking
things or thinking substance
you